We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Here's just a little break from from the depressing
politics.
There's a really funny debate going on in
our audience right now about whether I am
providing too much of a setup for the video
and audio clips that I play on the show.
Here's a caller who thinks I should be providing
more of a setup.
Take a listen to this.
Hi, David.
I'm calling in.
Heavy support of your usual format of preloading
as before you play a clip.
In normal presenting of information, I love
the idea of getting straight to the content
and then analyzing it after.
And I respect those who who have requested
that.
However, when in the case stuff coming out
of the Republican administration would trump
himself.
It is so full of spin and desolating, which
is kind of abusive, that preloading us with
information for me really helps relieve the
pain.
Of.
I'm happy to hear it.
And also, it is a vaccination against the
upcoming sprint.
Makes me much more immune to it.
I did, actually.
So I'm a strong supporter of the employee
front loading.
OK, so my idea for years has been I'm not
like I'm not a video playback technician.
The idea here is I'm giving you my take.
And so I try to prepare people for what we're
going to see.
And I certainly give more of a lead up to
clips than some other hosts might.
And it was deliberate.
I was doing that on purpose.
And every once in a while, I would get e-mails
from people saying, David, just give us the
clip and then analyze it so that you're not
tainting our view and and sort of priming
us to believe one thing or the other.
Then after tell us what you think.
And by that time we'll have made it made our
own sort of judgment of it.
And I tried that yesterday and I've tried
it a little more recently.
And I have to tell you, overwhelmingly, overwhelmingly,
the reaction was, no, no, David, don't just
play the clips, don't you?
Don't be a video playback clerk, essentially.
We are here for you to give us context.
And the context before is actually important.
So this is not a huge deal.
It's an interesting difference of opinion
among the audience.
But point taken.
And the response overwhelmingly in the last
24 to 48 hours is please go back to the old
way.
Tell us what we're about to see.
And we can still say we disagree with you,
but we like to see what is your take on what
we're about to see.
So I'll probably go back in that direction.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
One of the things I want to talk about is
why is the post office being discussed in
business terms?
And what I mean by that is the post office
is a public service.
And President Trump and his donor, Postmaster
General Lewis Dejoy, they're talking about
it like it's a business and it should be evaluated
and handled like a business that is supposed
to turn a profit.
That's not actually what it's supposed to
do.
And I want to address that on the bonus show.
We're also going to talk about the reality
that Donald Trump, although he is now assailing
the character of Kamala Harris, actually donated
to her multiple times.
We'll talk about that.
And then lastly, Lebanon's leaders were warned
in July about explosives at the port.
According to some documents and we are going
to explore that in detail.
All of this is on the bonus show.
Get instant access to the bonus show by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com.
And remember, August twenty third.
The 15 year anniversary of the David Pakman
show, we will have a huge one day membership
special to be notified of that special get
on my newsletter.
It's free at David Pakman dot com.